keiner erklärt wie er warum sich die
welt nicht erklären lässt kein philosoph
vor ihm hat als börsenhändler so viele
millionen verdient kein statistiker hat
die ein erfolgreicheres buch geschrieben
als er mit dem schwarzen schwan der mann
der wie kaum ein anderer banker mit dem
bauch bis sie über leute wie hillary
clinton oder nobelpreisträger joseph
stiglitz rc will aber weder philosophen
auch statistiker sein sondern einfach
ein gelehrter der unter dem begriff anti
fragilität ein welt gesetzt entdeckt hat
für das es bislang nicht einmal einen
namen gab vielleicht nennt man ihn
deswegen in der presse auch den
heißesten denke auf dem planeten und ich
begrüße ihnen wärmstens in unserem
studio
danke es ist mir eine große ehre in der
schweiz zu sein
nassim taleb sie sind reich sie sind
einer der meistbeachteten
intellektuellen der welt sagen sie war
das ist was ich immer wollte oder damals
als bub im libanon haben sie von ganz
anderem geträumt wollten sie vielleicht
außenminister des landes werden wie ihre
urgroßvater und großvater
ich habe ironischerweise tatsächlich
immer davon geträumt ein intellektueller
zu heben ich habe versucht
schriftsteller zu werden
ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich
wahrscheinlich
ich mochte das rampenlicht zumindest am
anfang aber inzwischen genieße ich es
nicht mehr
und vor etwa vier jahren habe ich mich
etwas zurückgezogen in die forschung
sie wollten berühmt werden so als
romanschriftsteller etwas politisches
naja aber dann machte ich das doch nicht
es ist so wie wenn sie im restaurant
essen bestellen
es ihnen zunächst schmeckt sie es
nochmals versuchen und dann merken dass
es nichts für sie ist und sie etwas
anderes wollen ich gehe lieber zu
mcdonald's ich habe eine andere laufbahn
eingeschlagen vom schreiben von büchern
für das allgemeine publikum ihn zum
schreiben für eine technische welt und
das gefällt mir besser
warum ist es war eine gewaltige
anstrengung dieses buch zu schreiben
es ist nicht meine persönliche sprache
sondern eine technische wenn ich etwas
in der technische sprache schreibe muss
ich mir keine sorgen machen nicht
verstanden zu werden ich muss mich nicht
darüber sorgen dass meine botschaft
irgendwo verstümmelt wird
es ist klar es ist mathematisch das ist
meine dritte karriere
so habe ich eine andere laufbahn
eingeschlagen üblicherweise schreiben
die leute zuerst technische sachen
beginnen hinterher für das allgemeine
publikum zu schreiben und werden dann
geschäftsleute ich habe es umgekehrt
gemacht
ich habe als geschäftsmann begonnen dann
in die schriftsteller geworden und ich
mochte es ich wollte damit erfolgreich
sein aber ich habe den erfolg nicht
gemacht und jetzt bin ich an meiner
dritten karriere und sie gefällt mir
diese karriere ist wie für mich gemacht
technische werke schreiben obwohl sie
sich nur an 100 leute richten
aber wissen sie was ich werde liebe von
100 leuten gelesen die das thema
wirklich würdigen als von millionen die
nicht viel darüber wissen jetzt ein
bisschen weil sie schreiben ja sehr gut
sie schreiben sehr bildhafte ihre these
eine große these ist ja die meisten
theorien die die menschheit seit
aristoteles gemacht hat sind falsch und
überschätzen sich und ich fand zum
beispiel die stelle wirklich toll in
ihrem buch an die fragilität wo sie das
zeigen wie wenig der mensch eigentlich
theoretisch kann mit der geschichte des
rollkoffer sie gingen einmal durch den
john-f -kennedy-flughafen in new york
und sie haben immer viele bücher dabei
und dann haben sie gestaunt dass der
rollkoffer nicht früher erfunden wurde
das ist eine beispielhafte geschichte
wie schlecht wir darin sind dinge zu
entdecken aber auch wie schlecht wir
dinge nutzen die wir schon entdeckt
haben
es gibt zwei die erste ist hart und
direkt etwas entdecken top da uns also
sprechen wir beispielsweise über das
rezept für den perfekten humus es gibt
zwei vorgehensweisen bei der ersten
holen sie sich spitzenwissenschaftler
von der eth geben ihnen eine wandtafel
und fordern sie auf eine formel zu
erarbeiten
ja wir einsteigen obwohl ein stein ja
nicht mit einer formel begonnen hatte
sie beginnen also schritt für schritt
mit der formel wir versuchen die
chemischen formeln der materialien hin
zu schreiben welche den perfekten humus
das perfekte kichererbsen muss ausmachen
das ist der eine weg damit werden wir
aber nicht so weit kommen
der zweite weg ist trial and error
versuch und irrtum
sie fügen etwas hinzu wenn es das
gericht verbessert und verändern
zufällig die beigaben in kleinen mengen
es schadet niemandem wenn sie sich ihre
wenn es ihnen nicht schmeckt geben sie
es ihre schwiegermutter oder sonst
jemandem
wenn es besser dann wissen sie welche
beigabe zum beispiel das olivenöl den
geschmack für mehrere leute verbessert
sie entdecken etwas durch versuch und
irrtum
wir haben also zwei weisen des
herangehens das kochen will ich es eine
praktische ernährung ist die mendel
vorgehensweise die römische
vorgehensweise ich nennen wir dass die
römische vorgehensweise die römer sind
so vorgegangen
die römer waren sehr heuristische extrem
praktisch anwendungsorientiert hatten
die hörer schon koffer koffer nein
aber was ich gemeint habe ist die
vorgehensweise des forschens schauen sie
die brücken an diese gebaut haben die
stehen immer noch die aquädukte
gelesen habe ist die maya hätten den
rollkoffer erfinden können wenn sie wenn
sie sich das besser überlegt hätten wir
kommen gleich zum rad in die zwei
methoden stehen im gegensatz zueinander
die griechische top down methode die
sich erfindungen aus denkt die griechen
machten einige erfindungen zum beispiel
eine dampfmaschine die aber nie zur
anwendung kam
die griechen hatten die dampfmaschine
aber sie haben sie nicht genutzt
sie haben sie nicht verwendet sie haben
den nächsten schritt nicht gemacht
wir haben also die intellektuelle top
down methode der entdeckung und wir
haben die praktische römische methode
also griechisch gegen römisch der
griechische weg hatte mathematik geführt
und zum plan wie eine dampfmaschine
aussehen könnte die sie aber nie
gebraucht haben die dampfmaschine ist
dann von abenteurern in großbritannien
wieder entdeckt worden welche völlig
ungebildet war
sprechen wir nun über den koffer wir
haben nicht genügend intellekt nicht
genügend wissenschaft um dinge zu
entdecken
wir haben sie zwar aber nicht genug für
die welt in der wir leben sie ist zu
komplex
wir entdeckten dinge durch trial and
error
wenn sie daran denken wie lange wir
gebraucht haben um diese bedeutende
anwendung zu entwickeln
können sie sich vorstellen heutzutage
noch schwerere koffer durch den kennedy
flughafen in new york zu schleppen
und sie haben immer sehr viele bücher
dabei und schwere bücher ich habe eine
menge bücher und reiseführer trotz
laptop und weniger bücher ist der koffer
immer noch sehr schwer
ich habe technische schriften in
elektronischer form aber ich kann keine
e-books lesen das ist gegen eine
ästhetik beginnen wir jetzt mit dem art
das rad ist in mesopotamien entwickelt
worden es gibt mannigfache verwendungen
in diesem 5.000 jahren
die maya china das rad nicht zu kennen
sie brauchten die sklaven gaben ihnen
wahrscheinlich kartoffeln und
peitschenhiebe
damit sich die gebäude baut es hat sich
nun aber gezeigt dass sie das rad dort
doch sie brauchten es für kinder
spielsachen
sie kamen nie darauf diese technik für
etwas anderes zu verwenden
bis der tüftler kam der gesagt hat lasst
uns diese reben im koffer bauen und das
ist jetzt nützlich sie haben den
rollkoffer wenn sie nachher zum
flughafen gehen wir alle haben
rollkoffer das stützt auch ihre radikale
aussage dass die meisten theorien grund
kreuz falsch sind und ich möchte das
zeichnet halt nein ich sage nicht dass
die theorien unrichtig sind
doch sie sind ungenügend und
überbewertet aber ich wollte darauf
hinaus oft ist der ansatz doch falsch
überspannt und ich finde es spannend wie
sie das mit drei vögeln zeigen metaphern
von drei vögeln ich will ein bisschen
ornithologie hier philosophische machen
zum beispiel der erste vogel vor denen
sie waren ist der dritte an sie sagen
ganz wichtig zu verstehen den menschen
seit kain truthahn warum sagen wir kein
brot allein
lassen sie mich den kontext der turn
geschichte zeigen es gibt zwei
lebenswelten in einer können wir dank
wissenschaftlicher technik menschen zum
mond bringen
wir könnten das sogar mit einem truthahn
aber wir können den verlauf der börse
von morgen nicht vorhersagen
es sind also zwei universen meint ruth
hand leicht eine skizze ein truthahn
wird vom metzger gemäß der jeden tag
1000 tage lang
das wird jeden tag dem truthahn
statistik angemeldet der
forschungsabteilung der tod an
zentralbank und so weiter alle
bestätigen dass der metzger truthähne
liebt und das vertrauen in die
statistiken
nun gibt es aber einen tag in den usa im
november an welchem es nie eine gute
idee ist truthahn zu sein
das mustangs kipping sein genau das
erntedankfest nun zwei tage vorher
bereitet der metzger dem truthahn eine
überraschung eine gewaltige überraschung
überraschung sagt genau eine gewaltige
überraschung so da stehen sich nun zwei
problem zuerst sein der keine truthähne
das ist das wichtigste
mein ansatz im ganzen ebner ist sorge
dafür dass du keinen truthahn bist sie
können alle informationen benutzen alles
was sie wollen aber seien sie ja keinen
truthahn
viele leute werden zu trennen weil sie
zu viele informationen haben welche sie
verwirren
dann überlegen sie sich statistik
technik auf dem falschen gebiet ich
meine die börse doch was funktioniert um
einen menschen auf den mond zu bringen
funktioniert nicht an der börse das ist
das erste
das zweite problem ist dass die leute
meine idee vom schwarzen schwan nicht
verstehen nur noch geld um das kapitel
mit dem tod armen trug dann
abzuschließen
das läuft darauf hinaus philosophisch
gesprochen auf das induktions problem
man kann aus dem was bisher geschah dann
frage ich sie aber sie sind hier jetzt
in der schweiz weil sie gesprochen haben
am finanz und wirtschaftsforum an durchs
land future 1 vortag den ja auch
angeschaut habe ist das nicht ein
widerspruch
sie sagen man kann keine prognosen
machen von den türken erfahrungen die
man hat und man lädt sie auf der ganzen
welt ein um hier über die zukunft zu
reden viele leute erwarten von mir
vorher sagen
ich kann aber nichts voraussagen die
ganze idee vom dran ist nicht
vorherzusagen sondern von metzgern
gewarnt zu werden
lassen sie mich diesen unterschied
erklären es ist das klassische
induktions problem ich habe es angepasst
indem ich etwas hinzugefügt habe den
schwarzen schwan gut
zuerst habe ich es in ein statistisches
konzept gebracht es gibt aber noch einen
anderen punkt welcher den leuten
entgangen ist
es ist ein schwarzer schwan für ein
truthahn aber es ist kein schwarzer
schwan für den metzger muss sich jetzt
wegen der ornithologie die wir hier
philosophisch betreiben wollen oder in
aller form den schwarzen schwan
einführen
was ist das war das große thema der
titel ihres letzten buches das sich
millionenfach verkauft hat was ist in
wenigen worten der schwarze schwan okay
nun es ist eine alte metapher aus
römischen zeiten so selten wie ein
schwarzer schwan
es gab dort wohl sehr wenige schwarze
schwäne in der logik bedeutet dies egal
wie viele ausschließlich weiße schwäne
sie beobachten können sie nicht
behaupten es gäbe keine schwarzen bleibt
weil man lange gedacht habt man hat nur
weiß ich wenn er auf der welt gesehen es
gibt keine frauen müssen sowie heiner in
australien glaub ich hab mit sache ja
aber die beobachtung eines einzigen
schwarzen schwans kann beweisen dass es
schwarze schwäne gibt doch die sichtung
einer million weißer schwäne kann kein
beweis dafür sein dass es keinen
schwarzen sparen gibt es gibt einen
unterschied zwischen der absenz von
evidenz und der evidenz von absenz ich
habe für phänomene plädiert welche nicht
bloß selten sind wieder vogel sondern
die zugleich eine große auswirkung haben
wenn sie auftauchen
was wären schwarze schwäne die uns
beschäftigt haben
ein positiver schwarzer sparen ist das
internet gewesen denn niemand hat es
kommen sehen und nun schauen sie mal was
es mit der welt angestellt hat der
elfter september waren lokal
ein schwarzer schwan und die
dampfmaschine war westlich ein schwarzer
schwan
warum waren nur lokal ein schwarzer mann
hat doch die ganze welt verändern
er hat mich die selbe auswirkung auf die
welt gehabt wie der zweite weltkrieg
oder der erste weltkrieg der ein großer
schwarzer schwan war sagten einige leute
voraus aber niemand sah voraus wohin er
führen und welche folgen er haben würde
wie viele leute umgebracht werden welche
veränderungen welche großen wandlungen
auf der landkarte europas es geben würde
lassen sie nicht hier auf einen
zentralen punkt kommen
ich kann einige arten von willkürlichen
ereignissen nicht voraussagen
wenn aber jemand ein geschäft auf zieht
und sich auf die vorhersagen verlässt
wird diese person zerbrechlich sein
ich kann also sagen ob eine struktur
verliehen ist oder nicht wenn sie nicht
auf vorhersagen bauen sind sie robust
sie müssen nicht sehr gut im voraus
sagen der zukunft sein darf ich wegen
dem stichwort robust den dritten vogel
einführen der eine rolle spielt in ihrem
buch das ist der phönix aber er ist
robust weil wenn er stirbt dann kommt
erst im frühjahr wieder kommt wieder so
zurück wie er war
aber lassen sie mich vorher zur anderen
idee der anti fragilität gehen lassen
sie mich etwas zur vorhersehbarkeit
sagen wenn jemand robust ist sagen wir
wenn 72 in ihren haben dann sind sie
robuster als mit einer sie müssen die
zukunft nicht voraussagen können weil
sie ein extra haben wenn sie geld auf
der bank haben was dasselbe bedeutet wie
wenn sie zwei nieren oder andere
redundanzen haben dann müssen sie nicht
sehr gut darin sein vorauszusehen was
sie dazu bewegen könnte das geld zu
benötigen denn sie haben es ja je mehr
puffer sie haben umso weniger
vorausschauend müssen sie sein
je mehr leverage also hebelwirkung sie
haben oder eva dealer sie sind umso mehr
müssen sie voraus schauen können
das leuchtet mir sehr ein aber sie
können doch für sich beanspruchen dass
sie noch besser waren als ein robuster
phoenix sie haben zum beispiel die
finanzkrise zweiter
7 2008 ein paar jahre vorher
vorhergesagt da kam ein journalist der
new york times trina in meinem buch der
schwarze schwan habe ich den zustand des
bankensystems beschrieben und ich habe
gesagt dieses system sei fragil die bank
fannie mae zum beispiel stand lange zeit
vor dem kollaps
sie war auf eine weise aufgebaut die
nicht mit extremen darlehen umgehen
konnte sie hatten ein blick gehabt in
vertrauliche interne papiere
nein sie können sich nur die risiken
anschauen das ist öffentlich einige
dinge waren öffentlich
der journalist der new york times warnte
mich wegen der tail risks die risiken am
ende der kette aber die erkennt man ja
aus der struktur er warnte mich davor
dass diese leute gefährdet waren
wenn sie auf dynamit sitzen wissen sie
dass dies letztendlich explodieren wird
viele andere banken und ich sehe die
banken als öffentlichen bereich hatten
dieselben risiken gegenüber
willkürlichen darlehen weil sie die
risiken mit dummen methoden berechneten
anstatt sich auf robustheit zu
fokussieren wollten sie versuchen zu
berechnen was in der zukunft geschehen
würde sie sagen die methoden waren
statistisch wissenschaftlich gesehen
stupid blöd
sie sind vollkommen blöd und alle diese
ökonomischen techniken und
risikoabschätzungen haben nie
funktioniert viele banken so die bank
für internationalen zahlungsausgleich in
basel lassen die banken diese methoden
anwenden
doch die funktionieren nicht haben es
nicht verstanden warum die zu blöd
nein 2008 hat man entdeckt dass sie
immer noch dieselben methoden anwendeten
aber wir wussten ja von 1994 dass diese
mit boden schlecht waren
ich wusste es von 1987 als sich mit tail
risk ereignissen konfrontiert wurde und
alle wussten als von 1994 dass diese
methoden große schwankungen nicht
vorhersehen
übrigens gibt es die beste forschung
über große schwankungen hier an der eth
zürich haben die besten der welt
dieses eth zentrum hat die beste
forschung über extreme schwankungen
macht hier in zürich
ich werde zurückkommen und sie immer
wieder besuchen nennt die haben
begriffen dass sie extreme risiken
anschauen müssen und nicht nur die
üblichen denn was zählt sind die extreme
und so kann man natürlich robustheit
aufbauen und sich gegen extreme schützen
ich teile die welt in zwei kategorien in
jene die verstehen dass es extreme
darlehen gibt und das sind diejenigen
die überleben werden und jene die das
nicht tun
sie können also vorher sagen dass
diejenigen die das nicht kapieren
letztlich kollabieren darf man sagen
sehr viele haben ist nicht rechtzeitig
verstanden sie blieben ein einsamer
rufer in der wüste und haben sich viele
feinde gemacht damit ich war nicht der
einzige doch ich hatte eben nicht den
üblichen ansatz sondern an den etwas
systematischeren ich habe ja von diesen
großen schwankungen gelebt also den
truthahn probleme alle 45 jahre
verdienen sie geld damit und das ist in
ordnung
ja ich war börsenhändlern setzte auf
diese ereignisse
man beginnt sich leute anzuschauen die
komplett scheiterten auch
nobelpreisträger dann merkt man dass
diese leute sehr gut darin sind
sicherheitsgurte einzubauen doch ihre
sicherheitsgurte funktionieren nicht bei
einem unfall
es gibt eine logische inkohärenz der art
und weise wie sie dinge berechnen sie
taugen für das gewöhnliche doch wen
kümmert schon das gewöhnliche sie müssen
sich über den flugzeugabsturz sorgen
nach nicht über schlechten kaffee im
flugzeug
das ist nicht das risiko mit dem
vorgehen konnten sie viel geld verdienen
der punkt ist nicht so sehr das geld
sondern vielmehr der intellektuelle
befund es gibt eine klasse von
ereignissen welche sie nicht
vorhergesehen haben hunderttausende
individuen sind ins ökonomische leben
involviert durch vorhersagen analysen
all die dinge die sie nicht sehen konnte
die idee ist aber den nächsten schritt
zu machen und zu schauen dass sie robust
die aufnahme des schwarzen schwans war
für mich enttäuschend
er ist sehr zurückhaltend aufgenommen
worden weil die leute die botschaft des
schwarzen spaness nicht verstanden haben
sie mochten das buch sie kauften das
buch haben aber die botschaft nicht
verstanden
außer ein paar wenigen
sie haben nicht wirklich bemerkt dass
sie auf die robustheit gegenüber dem
schwarzen schwan achten sollten anstatt
zu versuchen schwarze schwäne
vorherzusehen
damit können sie manövrieren sie können
sagen dass alles was fragiles zerbrechen
wird
ich werde fragil gleich definieren ich
kann sagen
diese brücke ist fragil und wird in 30
jahren nicht mehr da sein
ein römischer aquädukt ist robuster und
einer wie der bodyguard wird auch in 30
jahren noch da sein
stimmt es wie sie schreiben dass die
römischen ingenieure unter der brücke
schlafen mussten diese gewalt hatten
und die schweizer haben eine ähnliche
struktur
das prinzip ist das zu essen was man
selber gekocht hatte eine struktur die
auf lange sicht gute leistungen
hinbringt sind systeme in welchen die
leute lokal für irrtümer bezahlen
einzige land in welchem von einem
bankmanager geld zurück verlangt wurde
war die schweiz 2009 dann tut also mal
noch mit ein bisschen abfindung aber
wenigstens aus dem spiel genommen indem
sie ihm den bonus wieder weggenommen
habe
reden wir über die struktur wenn sie
einen bonus struktur haben in welcher
leute fehler machen und dafür nicht
bestraft werden
etwa wie in washington dann läuft schief
denn große staaten und zentralisierung
funktionieren nicht weil die leute nicht
direkt für ihre fehler bezahlen wenn sie
aber bottom up also von unten nach oben
induktiv organisiert sind
ausgehend von den kantonen und sie in
dieser gemeinschaft fehler machen
empfinden sie scham und das ist eine art
der abschreckung welche sie daran
hindert gewisse fehler zu machen denn
sie leben in einer gemeinschaft
die schweiz hat einen bottom-up-ansatz
also von unten nach oben und das
beschreibe ich an meinem buch deshalb
läuft es hier besser denn die meisten
leute bezahlen für ihre irrtümer ja also
als schweizer leser bekommt man eine
stolz geschwellte brust beim der lektüre
bei der lektüre weil sie sagen
vielleicht ist die schweiz das solideste
land der welt warum ich weiß nicht was
jetzt und in zukunft passiert bis vor
vier jahren haben die leute das
politische system nicht verstanden
wir müssen aber zuerst über die
verletzlichkeit die fragilität sprechen
können wir nun über die fragilität
sprechen
ich wollte nur noch mir noch mal
erlauben kurz nachzubohren dass sie als
börsenhändler reich geworden sind das
habe ich ja erlaubt mir so offen hier
ihnen vor zumal er ja noch nein es gibt
doch in amerika sprechen
das ist ja auch diese idee die
theoretiker ähnlich sehen bereich
gewarnt was fasziniert mich es hängt
davon ab was sie als reich bezeichnet
nein 1987 in meinen 20ern bin ich
unabhängig geworden und ich musste dafür
arbeiten
aber das war weitgehend zu fällen ich
dachte zwar daran dass seltene
ereignisse wirklich eintreffen würden
aber ich dachte nicht daran dass ich von
diesen so sehr profitieren könnte 1987
wurde ich unabhängig ich war nicht sehr
daran interessiert reicht zu lesen ja
1987 dann hatte ich noch zwei weitere
episoden die letzte war in der periode
2008 2009 also nach dem schwarzen schwan
ich habe den erfolg wiederholt es ist
aber nicht der springende punkt reich zu
sein oder nicht sondern unabhängig zu
sein
ich habe immer gesagt unter anderem in
meinem aphorismus buch das das
schlimmste ist nicht frei
zu sein man kann sehr reich aber unfrei
seien zum beispiel ein portier kann
freier sein als der
verwaltungsratsvorsitzende eines
unternehmens die idee ist eine gewisse
intellektuelle unabhängigkeit zu haben
damit sie nicht von ihrem job abhängig
sind
sie sind robuster als porträt oder bus
chauffeur oder sonst etwas bei einem
minimalen oder wenig darüber
sie sind robuster als wenn sie ein
unternehmen leiten ja schon aber die
sind intellektuell nicht frei ich will
intellektuell frei sein
ich habe nicht die vorstellung gleich zu
sein sondern frei genug zu sein so dass
man sich nicht über wirtschaftliche
folgen für alles was man tut sorgen
machen ist die idee wohlstand wird für
mich nicht durch kaviar und champagner
und teuren wein ausgedrückt war das der
moment den sie im buch beschreiben wo
sie irgendwo in new york sie sagen sogar
welche street aber ich weiß es nicht
mehr
ihre krawatte weggenommen haben
weggeworfen haben und in ihre
dachwohnung gegangen sie in görlitz nach
dem börsenkrach zog ich eines tages
meine krawatte aus und warf sie in den
mülleimer an der ecke park avenue in der
gehen sie mal nachsehen was aus ihr
geworden ist seither trage ich keine
krawatte mehr
für mich ist frei seien wichtiger als
gleich sein dann gingen sie in ihre
dachwohnung und haben mindestens zwei
kalte winter lang lese ich im buch
nachgedacht mit einer teetasse in der
hand und jetzt kommen wir zur fragilität
nein die idee der fragilität oder
zerbrechlichkeit ist mir viel später
gekommen seine sieben gemacht ich habe
keinen allein das ist nero ich habe
keine dachwohnung ich mag keine substanz
das war aber nie in einer datei nicht
luxus ein ein günstiges appartement ich
habe das so stand sogar in die karl
heinz sie gingen und haben sich die zeit
genommen lange nachzudenken
nein die geschichte von nero ist leicht
anders als meine persönliche geschichte
das ist nicht zu verwechseln
ich habe die finanzwelt vor etwa zehn
jahren verlassen
davor verbrachte ich etwa 20 jahre als
börsenhändler
ich verließ die finanzwelt und kam
wieder zurück nachdem ich meinen doktor
gemacht hatte als ich die finanzwelt
dann wirklich verlassen habe nach über
20 jahren schaute ich mir eines tages
eine kaffeetasse an etwas fragiles
zerbrechliches ich sagte oh die ist
fragil und sie mag keine unordnung
dann begann ich mit der ökonomischen
forschung
das hat sich erst neulich in den letzten
drei jahren voll entwickelt und weshalb
ich jetzt den vollzeit ökonomische
forschung betreibe ist weil ich von der
aussage das ist fragil und mag keine
unordnung hin wird zur aussage das ist
fragil weil es keine unordnung mag
oder anders gesagt alles was fragil ist
mag keine unordnung
das ist der schlüssel wenn es hier ein
erdbeben gibt hat dieses glas dann
irgendwas zu gewinnen nicht wirklich und
nur wenn sie damit einen fehler machen
kann es entweder so bleiben oder
zerbrechen aber nicht besser werden
so habe ich plötzlich die generelle idee
definiert
fragil ist das was keine unordnung mag
was keine unordnung mag mag auch die
zeit nicht keine zufälligen ereignisse
sondern mag ordnung dann ist robust also
was sich nicht um unordnung kümmert das
ist der springende punkt und das hat es
vorher nicht gegeben
das war unser phoenix aber jetzt ein
phönix sein genügt nicht man muss wie
die hydra sein wenn dies alles in
ordnung kommt wenn kopf weg dann
profitiert man sogar ja genau das sind
allgemein die art von dingen die etwas
unordnung mögen bis zu einem gewissen
punkt also mehr oder weniger man kann
wissenschaftlich mathematisch darstellen
dass es strukturen gibt welche keine
volatilität keine unstetigkeit keine
sprunghaftigkeit mühlen und im
börsenhandel wussten wir eine menge über
volatilität
ich war auf volatilität spezialisiert es
gibt dinge die keine volatilität mögen
und es gibt solche die das finanzpaket
im profitieren von aufruhr für den
unterschied zwischen den beiden gibt es
ein wort derivate komplexe derivate eine
meiner spezialitäten aber es kommt im
kulturellen vokabular überhaupt nicht
vor
sie haben soll die sprachen abgecheckt
nirgendwo gab es für diese idee dass
etwas unter stress profitiert
nein
doch wir suchten weiter nach einem wort
ich fragte dann nach dem gegenteil von
fragil dass es zu lied und zerbrechlich
gesund und belastbar
aber das bedeutet eben nicht das
gegenteil von etwas das durch unordnung
beschädigt wird sondern das gegenteil
ist etwas das durch unordnung gewinnt
hier suchten im französischen ankers
abel
nein das auch nicht auch kein deutsches
wort wir suchten weiter in den sozialen
netzen dank dem internet gibt es ja ein
großes publikum das man fragen kann
wir hatten die hoffnung vielleicht auch
ein boarding armenisch zu finden aber es
erwies sich als sackgasse
wir versuchten alles bis hin zum
chinesischen auch da war nichts
doch besuchten noch wochenlang weiter
ich fragte dann die leute mit einem post
bitte sagt was das gegenteil von
fragiler gibt es ein wort welches das in
eurer sprache beschreibt
natürlich gab es viele falsche resultate
wir konnten am ende kein wort finden
also in der menschlichen kultur geht's
nicht in der natur schon die natur die
natur versteht das und wir tun das auch
lassen sie mich das so sagen was von der
unordnung profitiert profitiert von der
zeitlichen dauer von schocks und unruhe
wir haben das bei innovationen gesehen
es gibt unternehmen etwa
pharmaunternehmen die machen fair
sie suchen nach einem hoch wirksamen
medikament und entdecken wie ag das war
keine absicht sondern ein kleiner fehler
das ist anti fragil wenn sie von einem
fehler profitieren
einfach keine fehler zu nutzen um
nachher geld
damit zu verdienen das ist anti fragiles
ja genau und diese begriffe haben sie
jetzt ein sarg wird dass der titel
programm verbessern
aufgrund das willkürlichkeit mag
darwin hat es bemerkt aber er hat im
begriff anti fragil nicht gebraucht
lassen sie mich das erklären
anti fragilität profitiert von zufällen
und fehlern
der grund warum sie und existieren ist
die dns denn wenn sich die dns vermehrt
dann ist das als ob man eine fotokopie
machen würde
mit einem fehler wenn der fehler
nutzbringend ist dann der fis pcs besser
falls es aber ein richtiger fehler ist
ergibt sich nichts daraus die
zufälligkeiten hinter umwelt helfen des
pcs also sich zu verbessern hauptberuf
aber das ist gut für die spezies nicht
für das individuum in insofern ist das
ist nicht gut für das individuum aber
für die spezies wir müssen aus der
perspektive des kollektivs denken fehler
zum beispiel im gastgewerbe nutzen der
ganzen restaurant industrie nicht aber
dem einzelnen restaurant das den fehler
gemacht hat
wir müssen in größeren begriffen denken
was für das system und weniger für das
individuum gut ist wenn morgen ein
flugzeug abstürzt ist das eine
schreckliche nachricht für die leute an
bord schrecklich für die familien und
alle anderen
das würden wir lieber nicht haben sie
müssen aber daran denken dass es schon
einen tag nach her viel sicherer sein
wird für alle die fliegen
viele leben werden durch das system
gerettet was mich umbringt macht sie
stärker nicht wie nie gesagt hat was
mich nicht umbringt genau es bringt mich
um macht sie aber stärker
kommen wir zurück zu dem spezies darwin
hat begriffen deshalb sie sich
entwickelten ob schon eher
wahrscheinlich nichts über genetik
wusste aber die natur nutzt fehler auf
zwei ebenen
die erste ist die ebene der dns die
andere ist die zufälligkeit in der
umwelt wenn die umwelt nicht zufällig
ist gibt es keine selektion die umwelt
trägt gewisse variationen in sich und es
gibt individuen die dadurch besser
gedeihen
man braucht eine gewisse art von
schwankungen und veränderungen um sachen
zu verbessern
dass aber auch auf der menschlichen
ebene auf ihrer ebene wenn sie zum
beispiel stressfaktoren und gewisse
schwankungen haben geht es ihnen besser
die leute merken gar nicht wie
universell das ist bis zu einem gewissen
grad
wenn sie und ich eine zeitlang im
weltraum wären würden wir an
knochendichte verlieren und das
verstehen die leute sie haben also eine
ahnung von anti fragilität wenn sie
merken dass sie ins fitnessstudio
sollten
warum sollten sie ins fitnessstudio
gehen um ihren körper zu quälen das
wollte ich sie fragen welche strategie
jetzt nicht als spezies sondern als
einzel mensch muss sich haben um an die
frage zu werden zum beispiel ok training
in den fitnessclubs stellen wir das in
einen allgemeinen kontext als erster
sie wollen nicht fragil seien um nicht
fragil zu sein um schwarze spinne zu
vermeiden dürfen sie nicht paranoid sein
sondern müssen sich auf die großen
risiken konzentrieren
auf persönlicher ebene sind das ganz
einfache techniken erstens steigen sie
nie in ein flugzeug das nicht von profi
piloten geflogen wird
bei den profis der fluggesellschaften
schon sie haben in den usa 22 millionen
flugbewegungen jährlich ohne tödlichen
unfall zwei schließen sie sich nicht der
mafia werden sie kein mitglied der mafia
brauchen sie nicht und meiden sie zucker
mit diesen vier regeln verlängern sie
ihre lebenserwartung gewalt und das
machen sie alles sie sind nicht nur ein
statistischer werden es gibt noch eine 5
regel und sie können es zu zehn gehen
fahren sie nicht motorrad
sie können das für jeden bereich machen
für ihr portfolio und andere dinge um
von der anti fragilität zu profitieren
haben sie bis hierher die großen risiken
und negativen zustände vermieten schnell
dazwischen zu fragen
also paranoid sein wenn es um die großen
risiken geht
viele würden sagen zumal vielleicht
motorradfahrer also dann ist die freude
aus dem leben weg beim motorrad die ja
ich weiß aber man kann auch viele andere
weisen spaß haben ohne große risiken
einzugehen
bergsteigen ist nicht gut ob schon die
wahrscheinlichkeit sehr kleines sich
umzubringen aber kumulativ eben doch
denn wenn man es überlebt macht man es
wieder und wieder und dadurch wird die
lebenserwartung viel kleiner
aber sie sind nicht gegen vergnügen im
leben ich bin dafür spaß im leben zu
haben
solange man lebensbedrohliche elemente
beseitigt
dann kann man gewisse risiken und
schwankungen tolerieren weil sie
begrenzt sind sie müssen das entfernen
was ich als schwanz als das ende
bezeichnen
nur weil ich hatte vor ein paar wochen
am tisch hier die besten schweizer
bergsteiger die machen das natürlich
ganz falsch von ihnen aus gesehen die
riskieren ihr leben
sehr oft aber die sagen mir das ist der
sinn des lebens
na gut vielleicht ich spreche nicht von
existenziellen angelegenheiten ich sage
bloß lassen sie sich nicht täuschen wenn
sie gewisse arten von risiken eingehen
sie gehen das risiko ein zu sterben
dabei gibt es viele andere dinge die sie
tun können und die viel besser für sie
sind und die nicht als große risiko
beinhalten also den schwarzen schwan und
die sie dennoch von unordnung
profitieren lassen
als erstes können sie abweichungen in
ihre essgewohnheiten bringen
essen sie nicht regelmäßig fassten sie
zwischendurch essen sie mal viel und mal
gar kein fleisch sogar uns bevor waren
bringen sie abwechslung und aufregungen
um ihr leben
gehen sie manchmal in extreme kälte oder
extreme hitze bleiben sie nicht immer in
der gleichen temperatur gehen sie ins
fitnessstudio und schocken sie ihren
körper und erleben sie auch
schwierigkeiten in ihrem leben noch
genauer heranzogen weil was ich gelesen
habe dort machen sie richtig harte
übungen sie nehmen die schwersten
gewichte und machen solches zeug was die
die muskeln richtig beamte in den handel
sie fordern mit dem gewicht heben auch
ihre knochen und stämmen einmal die
woche so viel gewicht bis sie nicht mehr
gehen können und die zahlen spielen
keine grosse rolle aber was ich tue ist
für mein alter gut sie haben es bis
hierhin hoch nur einmal das
maximalgewicht das ist aber nicht die
eigentliche idee sondern es gibt eine
kategorie von dinge noch eine sekunde
wenn ich darf weil sie schreiben auch
sie haben uns ein bisschen auch gemacht
diese übung mit den hanteln weil sie
bedroht wurden also dauern richtige
risiken sie haben die bankenwelt
verärgert nach der finanzkrise und sie
wollten zuerst ein bodyguard
stellen und am schluss sahen sich selber
aus schreiben sie wie ein metzger oder
ein bodyguard nach der finanzkrise 2009
kam ich hierher in die schweiz
ich war in davos zum ersten und letzten
mal ich wurde gewarnt dass sich gewisse
leute verprügeln wollte im fitnessstudio
sprach ich mit einem kollegen darüber
und einem mächtigen kerl einem
leibwächter
dieser bot mir an mitzukommen dann
dachte ich darüber nach und fragte ihn
wie er leibwächter gebäuden seien dann
erklärte mir diese kultur
sie machen eine minimale anzahl
wiederholungen stimmen dabei aber das
maximum das sie können das muss man
zuerst lernen und ab und zu gibt's
verletzungen so wie ich sie gerade oben
an der schulter habe wenn sie einen
kleinen fehler mit großen gewichten
machen können sie einen monat keines
mehr
aber lassen sie mich ihnen zuerst die
allgemeine idee geben dann können wir
zur spezifischen gehen
haben sie schon mal etwas von
posttraumatischer störungen deshalb
ermutige ich die leute sich dingen
auszusetzen die zur posttraumatischen
belastungsstörungen führen können
die leute verstehen nämlich nicht dass
es auch posttraumatisches wachstum gibt
und dass tritt weit häufiger auf als
posttraumatische störungen
das geht man muss sich den nur aussetzen
sie müssen sich schwierigkeiten
aussetzen die sie nicht umbringen nicht
so wie das motorrad sondern einer
mäßigen mengen stressfaktoren seien
diese nun physische stressfaktoren wie
gewichte stemmen hitze hunger oder
ähnliches oder psychische
als ich während des krieges im libanon
war in der mittelschule starben meine
freunde auf dem schulweg mindestens
sechs meiner klassenkameraden wurden im
krieg getötet man denkt wer das mit
ansieht muss traumatisiert sein
das war ja doch ich war überhaupt nicht
traumatisiert meine schule war nicht
weit weg von der grünen linie 200 meter
von der demarkationslinie entfernt bin
ich traumatisiert
nein also dachte ich nach vielleicht bin
ich dadurch besser geworden
dann sah ich mir die literatur an und
berief mich auf das was man
posttraumatisches wachstum nennt
mit anderen worten vorfälle und schocks
welche sie in ihrem leben gehabt haben
führen generell zu verbesserungen nur in
seltenen fällen führen sie zu traumata
die leute sprechen aber nicht über
posttraumatisches wachstum sondern über
posttraumatische störungen denn
psychologen verdienen kein geld damit
sie von posttraumatischem wachstum zu
heilen aber wie wissen wir oben ich das
zeugs umbringen werde oder nicht bei dem
flugzeug haben sie eine gute regel nur
professionelle piloten weiterexistenz
sowie weiß ich wie weit ich gehen soll
was uns umbringen wird ist in der tat
das fehlen von schocks und traumata das
gewicht heben wird sie nicht umbringen
sondern ihre lebenserwartung erhöhen
wir müssen das auswählen weil sie nicht
umbringt bergsteigen kann sie umbringen
wandern aber nicht ja wenn sie jung sind
sollten sie einen beruf ergreifen
ich ging zum börsenhandel man denkt das
sei ein gefährlicher beruf und stetig
mit traumata
doch nein ganz und gar nicht wenn man
jung ist setzt man sich vielen top
ereignissen aus man holt alles heraus
man wird gefeiert
man geht risiken ein doch diese risiken
sind nicht tödlich das meine ich
sie müssen in ihrem leben genug
abwechslung haben damit sie besser
werden können
später sprechen sie auch von einer
handelsstrategie aber jetzt nicht im
fitnessclub die handlung sondern sie
sagen man soll sich riesig um es sich so
verhalten dass man zb sein geld 90
prozent an lebt ganz sicher ganz
langweilig und zehn prozent richtig
verrückt klasse ist die hand genau um zu
vermeiden bankrott zu gehen
das ist etwa dasselbe wie wenn sie
vermeiden in einem helikopter mit ihrem
cousin zu steigen diese idee können sie
in jeden bereich übertragen wenn sie ein
gutes portfolio wollen legen sie den
großen teil sehr sicher an einen kleinen
teil aber setzen sie dem größten risiko
aus welches sie eingehen können und
nicht alles im mittelweg danach nichts
in der mitte nichts
ich habe mir 27 bereiche angeschaut die
ich in meinem buch aufliste in welchen
eine firma dasselbe tun könnte ein
großer teile geschäfte laufen
konventionell man verkauft zum beispiel
schokolade der rest hingegen wie google
versucht das nächste neue geschäft zu
finden
auf einer seite gibt es also viele
risikofreude und auf der anderen kaum
risiken gibt es diese strategie auch bei
den vögeln zum beispiel und bei den
menschen gehen wir zu den vögeln bei den
weibchen hat man gemeint sie seien treue
und monogam weil sie beim gleichen
menschen geben sie wählen ein solides
aber langweiliges männchen als gattin
aus doch sie betrügen erst mit dem
rockstar der rockstar ist als gefährte
zum flatterhaft also nehmen die weibchen
den zuverlässigen betrügen ihn aber in
fünf bis zehn prozent der fälle mit dem
rockstar die nachkommenschaft beste
beweis dafür sogar die menschen machen
das viele studien aus dem tierreich
bestätigen dass die monogamie ein
schwindel ist
die leute haben typischerweise eine
duale strategie bei den menschen hat man
das herausgefunden als in großbritannien
die dns tests begannen sie zeigen in
etwa dasselbe verhältnis nicht alle
vögel sind monogam aber auch nicht alle
sind untreu das verhältnis ist etwa wenn
sie in ihrem leben schriftsteller werden
wollen haben sie zwei optionen
die erste ist dass sie für eine zeitung
schreiben dass wir die ganze energie
auffressen
[Musik]
suchen sie sich also lieber die
einfachste stelle die sie finden können
arbeiten sie als portier oder in einem
job der sie intellektuell nicht
ausbremst
dann gehen sie am wochenende nach hause
und schreiben ihre romane
das ist viel besser als die ganze zeit
etwas dazwischen zu machen
ich habe das selbst bin als ich
börsenhändler war war ich ein viel
besserer forscher als jetzt da ich
professorin in der mittel funktioniert
es und tatsächlich wenn man die
geschichte von schriftstellern oder von
forschern betrachtet sieht man dass all
diese leute wie ich es nenne eine hantel
hatten einstein war ein einfacher
angestellter und arbeitete an seinen
schriften gut darin bereich englische
landfahrer hatten einen bequemen
langweilige beruf und widmeten sich da
neben der forschung
solche leute haben hunderte von dingen
entdecken das zeigt diese ampel
strategie funktioniert wenn wir noch
kurz wieder einen blick jetzt nicht auf
einzelne menschen werfen sondern auf
organisationen kann man sagen die banken
haben unterdessen auch vernünftige anti
fragile strategien heraus gefunden oder
sind die immer noch too big to fail und
werden alles kaputtmachen
viele merken nun dass man robust sein
muss aber sie haben die illusion dass
sich robustheit erreichen lässt indem
man in der mitte steht sie merken aber
nicht dass man auch risiken eingehen
muss sie bleiben konventioneller auch
die schweizer sind
irgendwie die banken waren klug bist die
ubs amerikanische firmen aufkaufte
inzwischen sind sie wieder schlauer
nun wollen sie im grenzüberschreitenden
geschäft kooperieren und gehen nur ein
paar marginale risiken
sie waren sehr robust bis sie versuchten
die amerikanischen banken nachzuahmen
doch nun werden sie wieder sehr robust
reden wir nun über die systeme ein
system mit vielen variationen ist
generell viel besser als ein
zentralisiertes und die schweiz
funktioniert er von unten nach oben
als ich hier über die schweiz sprach
habe ich gesagt lenin war als flüchtling
in der schweiz und versteckte sich hier
um weiterzukommen
nabokov sein kompletter gegenspieler bei
ebenfalls als flüchtlinge und keiner
dieser flüchtlinge die hier aus
politischen gründen schutz suchten
dachte jeder an dass sie wohl etwas von
der schweiz in ihrem eigenen land
anwenden sollen
wir sind offen wir geben den roten wie
lenin den weißen wie nabokov asyl und
die möglichkeit ihre linien hatte in der
zentralbibliothek in zürich viel
doch warum waren sie hier
weil es hier stabil war und warum war
stabil
niemand hat damals realisiert warum es
stabil lenin zog aus um seinen großen
staat aufzubauen
sie haben nicht gemerkt dass der
schlüssel zur stabilität in diesem land
die breite verteilung von
entscheidungsfindung ist das fehlen
eines zentralstaat diesen gedanken will
ich jetzt aus letztes kapitel für die
letzten paar minuten aufnehmen was
können wir sagen wenn wir jetzt in die
zukunft blicken über die welt sie sind
nicht für zentral staaten sie sagen die
sind eben nicht am thie fragil wenn sie
schauen
welche entwicklung zum beispiel die usa
was dort passieren wird sie mögen
hillary clinton überhaupt nicht habe ich
gelesen sind sie pessimistisch dass
entwicklungen lassen sie mich zuerst
etwas sagen dass man in der politik
wissenschaft nicht kennt und über das
ich geschrieben habe
ich habe viele wissenschaftliche
beiträge für zeitschriften verfasst und
auch einen für die us-amerikanische
regierung in denen ich versuche die
risiken in verschiedenen ländern
abzuschätzen
der große irrtum dabei ist verschiedene
regimes zu vergleichen und zu sagen
dieses land ist kommunistisch und jenes
hat eine freie marktwirtschaft und
deshalb ist dieses land besser als das
andere
gut das kann man tun aber vergessen sie
nicht dass etwas viel wichtiger ist die
größe wieso die größe weil kleine dinge
anders funktionieren als große nehmen
sie einen elefanten der ist keine große
maus wenn man ein ding vergrößert muss
man das gerüst die knochen und deren
dichte noch weit größer machen etwa bei
einem tee warum weil sich die sachen
nicht wirklich proportional verhalten
also ich würde die ich verstehe den
gedanken aber die usa sind jetzt einfach
ein elefant nein die usa sind kein
elefant sondern nur ein staatenbund
seine föderation oder sie waren das
zumindest vor der regierung obama aber
nehmen wir china
vergleichen sie den elefanten china mit
der maus singapur und merken sie dass
sie beim vergleichen von systemen nicht
regimes vergleichen dürfen sondern
zuallererst auf die größe fokussieren
müssen
und zum schluss was uns am meisten
interessiert neben der schweiz die wir
besprochen haben ist die eu ist die eu
jetzt mehr ein dezentrales ding wie die
usa und kein elefant oder haben sie
angst für die halb dafür die eu und sage
ihnen
die eu hatte auf dem papier das prinzip
der subsidiarität
das ist eine intelligente form der
dezentralisierung
mit anderen worten man dezentralisiert
alles außer das militär und wichtige
dinge so wie in der schweiz
subsidiarität wie die katholische kirche
oder das römische weltreich waren
auf dem papier hat die eu diese mission
doch leider ist es so dass wenn man
bürokraten in brüssel zusammen bringt so
beginnen diese pommes frites zu essen
und vorschriften zu verfassen
wir regeln über die geschwindigkeit von
scheibenwischern und solches zeug
das ist nicht gut
es ist nur zum teil gut
frankreich ist ein top down land ein
zentralistischer stadt frankreich ging
es gut als man es nicht zentralisieren
konnte
nachdem man das land zentralisiert hat
ging es bergab die eu hilft
französischen städten paris zu umgehen
sie hilft barcelona sich von madrid zu
verabschieden dort ist die eu hilfreich
doch sie lässt sich in dinge hinein
ziehen welche das prinzip der
subsidiarität oder der katholischen
kirche gar nicht unterstützen
es ist faszinierend mit ihnen zu reden
sie haben gezeigt wie oft der mensch
sich täuscht wenn der theorien aufstellt
wir haben 120 sekunden noch diese möchte
ich nutzen um mit ihnen von ihnen einen
blick in die zukunft lassen zu machen
weil sie sagen wir wissen schon etwas
über die zukunft nämlich wir dürfen
nicht die neo man es gibt einen
einfachen weg in die zukunft zu blicken
als man in den 1950 er jahren
vorhersagen zu machen versuchte nahm an
die gegenwart als ausgangspunkt und
fügte fliegende motorräder hin zu pillen
welche unsere ernährung verändern würden
und eben all dieses moderne zeugs doch
der weg zur richtigen vorhersage ist
dass sie die gegenwart als ausgangspunkt
nehmen aber alles daraus entfernen das
zerbrechlich ist was es ist seltsam aber
wenn ich vorher sagen will wie die welt
in 30 jahren aussehen könnte würde ich
das was heute noch nicht 30 jahre alt
ist herausnehmen und sagen das andere
wird in 30 jahren noch da sein
also alles wegnehmen das noch nicht 30
jahre alt ist also zum beispiel ein buch
das vor 30 jahren nicht gelesen worden
ist wird auch in 30 jahren nicht gewesen
der weg zur vorhersage ist dass es viele
technologien gibt die nicht vorhersagbar
sind
was ich aber voraussagen kann ist dass
alles was jetzt neu ist durch etwas noch
neues ersetzt das alte aber dies hier
wird auch in 30 jahren noch da sein
das ist etwa 3000 jahre alt was aber
nicht bleiben wird ist wahrscheinlich
ein laptop der verschwinden und durch
etwas anderes ersetzt werden wird und
ihr buch dem ist zu wünschen dass es in
30 jahren noch da ist weil es ist
wirklich gut ich bedanke mich herzlich
für das gespräch und ich habe zuerst
gedacht sie sind einer der so als
statistiker sehr kühl keine romantik
kennt dann fand ich ganz hinten im buch
den satz wir leben in einer welt deren
zauber aus unserer unfähigkeit rührt sie
restlos zu verstehen ist also gut dass
wir nicht alles wissen herzlichen dank
nassim taleb danke sehr
es war mir eine große ehre hier zu sein
ein weltbekannter und eigenwilliger
banker ist auch nächste woche bei uns zu
gast meine kollegin barbara bleisch
spricht dann mit dem australischen star
philosophen peter singer der
menschenrechte für menschenaffen forever
oder eine radikale umverteilung des
reichtums zugunsten der armen und für
den selbst das folterverbot kein
absolutes tabu ist also ein
irritierender und zugleich überaus
inspirierender kopf auch nächsten
sonntag für heute danke für das
zuschauen und allen einen schönen tag
[Musik]
von der philosophie zur kunst